yes
I can't tell okay so I'm Aaron Cohen I'm
a professor in Department medical
informatics in the corporate immunology
you don't recognize me and this is our
regular Thursday conference and today we
have Rogers just work now I have the
blurb I didn't know before I read all
this
Roger holds a bachelor's degree in
general science and community health
studies from Portland State University
and is currently a master's of science
clinical informatics student in the
department of medical informatics and
clinical epidemiology here at OHSU his
current area of focus is on clinical
quality measurement broadly Raja has
interests in health care quality health
care data science and the use of health
information technology to support
clinical care in his role on David doors
team he has helped provide technical
assistance to clinics participating in
primary care transformation projects
including targeted technical assistance
around a chai tea and clinical quality
measures for AHRQ evidence now
initiative CMS's comprehensive primary
care initiative as well he has also
helped with the development of best
practice alerts in epic for the clinical
decision support IQ maple project and
also with the help of helping with the
implementation of select cqms in the
integrated care coordination information
system and with the preparation of
education materials for the Office of
National Coordinator for health
information technology training
curricular grant Russia is originally
from Portland Oregon and today he's
going to talk about his work looking at
a new language for clinical quality
measure description and implementation
and comparing those features of that
language with the old language and
what's good what's bad and where we're
going in the future so with that I will
so after all this thanks for reminding
me so after all their be patient then
they'll be question-and-answer period
then we kick you all out as community
gets to grill him a little bit make sure
he really knows his stuff and then he
gets to go out and wait while we all
discuss and make a final decision so
that you're ready to go okay thank you
so like Aaron said I assess the benefits
and challenges of clinical quality
language which is a new health level
seven international specification for
representing logic criteria for clinical
quality measures and clinical decision
support there's a lot of buzzwords there
I will hopefully define them throughout
this talk for you so in the United
States we spend a disproportionate
amount in our healthcare costs both
current and projected but Americans are
still more likely to die from
preventable conditions compared to
residents and other high-income
countries so therefore there have been
efforts to try to increase the value of
care delivered in the United States
however exacerbating these poor outcomes
and high costs is the fact that
historically our payment system has been
operated under a fee-for-service model
meaning that each service or unit of
care is funded individually and so this
may influence clinicians to provide an
increased volume of services rather than
better services and so when we talk
about increasing the value of care we
can think of this as the quality of care
delivered divided by its cost and
starting in 2019 at the Centers for
Medicare and Medicaid Services
our time payment to performance on
quality measures in a program called the
quality payment program and so this
program the quality payment program
requires hospitals and clinicians to
report electronic clinical quality
measures
or ecqms these are based on
evidence-based guidelines that track
structures processes and outcomes from
clinical data recorded in electronic
health record systems and while the
quality payment program is starting to
tide these performance on these measures
to the payment in 2019 there's actually
a long history of payment programs that
have required manual chart abstractions
but as EHRs have been rapidly adopted in
the last 10 years we now have these
official electronic clinical quality
measures that are now tied to pain and
so like I said these ecqms measure
quality at the population level they're
often reported at the hospital level or
the practice level for the and you a
great your patients who are seen during
a measurement period usually the last
year for example so I'm this slide I
define the various subpopulations that
are included in an ecqm specifically for
CMS ID 154 which I'll talk about
throughout my talk which looks at the
appropriate treatment for children with
upper respiratory infection so in Manisa
qm there's a denominator which is the
subset of patients whom your measure is
designed to address in CMS 154 that is
kids who are 3 months to 18 years old
who have a diagnosis of upper
respiratory infection you have a
numerator in an ecqm which is the subset
of the denominator for whom some type of
outcome or clinical action should occur
so in this measure it's the children in
the denominator who do not have a
prescription of an antibiotic biotic
within three days of their diagnosis and
some measures have exclusions where you
remove patients whether might be a
contraindication or where the therapy or
service is not appropriate and so in
this measure it's children who are
already taking antibiotics or who have a
competing diagnosis with upper
respiratory infection and so I mentioned
that these ecqms
rapidly evolved with the widespread
adoption of electronic health records
and so therefore the quality measurement
community also had to rapidly develop
standards to facilitate that
implementation and adoption of
e-cigarettes and so specifically CMS
endorsement a shin in the health quality
measure format or H qmf then these are
human readable specifications they
outlined the rationale for the measure
as well as the definition of those
different components the denominator and
the numerator and the exclusions in
addition they also defined the
structured sets of codes and terms to
define the clinical concepts or these
are called value sets and so this is all
human readable specification there's
also a machine readable spec in
extensible markup language XML however I
focused on the human readable
specification for my thesis specifically
also included in the human readable
definition is pseudocode and so this is
the pseudocode for CMS 154 it represents
the relationships between the clinical
concepts and it's based on a
standardized model called the quality
data model which defines relationships
between clinical concepts like diagnoses
and encounters for example and it ties
these two standards-based terminologies
and the goal of this is to facilitate
standardized quality measurement across
health institutions so to give you some
more background the context around
clinical quality measurement dates back
for decades and this preceded the
widespread adoption of electronic health
records so this required sampling an
annual chart reviews on a sample of
patient records and so these early
programs required that sort of manual
abstraction and then human
interpretation of the abstraction tools
so that you could submit those your
performance to CMS essentially or to
whoever was requiring the reporting and
then over time the measures were updated
to reflect new guidelines this required
new data collection techniques and
implementation techniques and then of
course in 2009 with
high-tech act and meaningful use
incentives which resulted in the
widespread adoption of EHRs we now have
even more efforts to try to standardize
how we measure healthcare quality and so
now we have health IT vendors and
healthcare organizations that aim to
manage all the standards and the goal is
to create shareable expression logic
between the sites however there are data
quality issues around completeness and
correctness and validation issues and
these apply to ecqm implementation so
that is sort of at the population level
when we think about clinical quality
measurement at the patient level this is
often represented by clinical decision
support our patient safety alert for
health maintenance reminders and the
logic expression for these alerts and
reminders have the same problems as
ecqms and so early implementers realized
that there needed to be this sort of
human intervention and handcrafting to
implement these sort of rules so they
encoded the pseudo similar to the pseudo
code I showed you for CMS 154 they
created if-then house logic to represent
about the rules and then in the 90s the
most popular one was called the Arden
syntax was pretty revolutionary
they had different categories and slots
and what was good about the Arden syntax
was a logic slot and so they were able
to really hone in on the if-then off
logic for these types of rules and there
was some promise of the ability for that
to be portable across sites however all
turned Arden syntax was this part which
was a curly brace and within the curly
brace was human readable text that
basically described to a human how to
map the rules to database processes so
that they could implement these rules
against a clinical data and this was a
problem because it required the same
intervention and handcrafting to really
make these things implementable and so
in the last 20 years hl7 and others
decided that the curly brace problem was
not solvable in art and syntax there
been a various efforts around creating
models and standards to try to address
this
however they haven't solved it it's to
this day then so this is a slide I stole
from or borrowing from the ECI Resource
Center so for those of you that have
experience working with clinical data
this probably should sound familiar to
you the fact that you can't just
implement an algorithm against your
database you have there is some mapping
of their decisions that you haven't they
made at the local level and so you can
see here with the implementation of an
ecqm
there's this cycle of conceptualizing
and testing and this you know
understanding the specification before
you're able to implement it and so
despite the fact that we have all these
standards which I've showed me we have
the H qm f representation your
standards-based terminologies there's a
lot of variation across the ecosystem we
have various networks and communication
channels and sets of organizations of
clinical data that currently exist so
implementers have to make these
decisions to map clinical data
institutions and just in case you don't
believe me i've actually studied this
variation i'm in collaboration with
doctors dormice cough and so as Erin
said in my intro I worked with clinics
in Oregon on quality improvement
initiatives we required the clinics to
submit data to us quarterly and in
addition to the variation that exists at
each clinic in terms of their local
decisions on how they handle their
clinical data they often resorted to a
certified health IT to generate their
ecqm data to submit to us so some use
their electronic health records some use
health IT registry systems and some had
back and access to their systems and
implemented their own theories and then
to add more variation to this is the
fact that the measures themselves are
updated at least annually sometimes two
to three times a year so there has to be
management of that as well and so in
quarter one of 2017 when we were
collecting data we knew that this
variation existed through the clinics
between their health IT that they're
using and then we knew that about
three-quarters of them worse than
being a 2015 version and one quarter was
submitting this new 2017 version and in
this version update were big changes to
the logic and the definitions and when
we looked at this what we found was that
between the 2015 and 2017 versions the
performance was different by up to 5%
and overall performance score and then
the denominators shifted by up to 28%
and the number of patients included we
also studied implementations based on
distinct value set specifications and we
altered look-back period in separate
papers and we found the same sort of
thing that the variation and the
specific criteria can really impact your
performance for and so looking back at
the paper we did about the different
versions of measures the bold call or
the bold rows are the aggregate measures
and then the sub rows we broke them
apart to just look at specific sub
population but you can see that you know
the the change in performance from 15 to
17 is on the very right you can change
up to 5% and in some cases between the
versions of performance decreased which
we don't versions and so when you reduce
this to a percentage like that that 5%
is enough to change the amount of money
that a clinic might receive for their
their payment reimbursement and then
focusing on the patients included this
is also important in terms of patient
safety so this is a Venn diagram looking
at the denominator their patients on the
left is the patients including included
in the 2015 version of the measure and
on the right is the patients including
it in the 2017 version of a measure and
so for this if you if you imagine that
the 2017 of them the most updated
accurate representation of this measure
is like perfect inclusion then what we
did was we took a number needed to treat
statistics and we estimated the number
of lives that might be saved if you
implemented a targeted quality
improvement intervention so the takeaway
for this slide is that if you have
accurate implementations and standard
representations of measures you might be
able to save lives and avoid harms for
patients and so this emerging standard
quality language is intended to do this
it's supposed to help with electronic
processing of ECM logic the new
specification for the pseudocode so it's
replacing their qdm HTML pseudocode it's
intended to include more natural
language descriptions increase
readability it's supposed to have a
human readable conceptual level language
to define these measures and so here
this is a little hard to read and I will
zoom into this and show you snippets of
this this is the hqm app quality data
model pseudo code representation for CMS
154 you can see there's a lot of ands
and ORS here with a list of boolean
logic and this is the cql representation
it's supposed to mimic a high-level
query language in addition to boolean
logic operators it has other things that
you might see in structured query
language for example like unions and
intersex there are identifiers and
there's function so you can see that
it's maybe closer to a programming
language and it's also so you know less
wordy according to the creators but less
worthy worthy and easier to interpret
and so these are from slides released in
April 2017 about the trajectory for cql
so currently this is what the ecqm our
calculation ecosystem sort of looks like
this is what I described to you you have
your HTML qvm the translator might be
the humans at a healthcare organization
and you have to manually interpret the
HTML and then apply it to your
calculation engine to calculate your
message in the near term and then
already sort of exists is the e LM the
expression logic module and this is a
way for so CGI was intended to be
machine readable so if you imagine that
a computer could decipher cql for you
automatically and then spit out a query
query that you could then manually
configure
and apply to your data set so it
facilitates the translating process and
thinking further aspirational the cql e
LM can sort of replace the translator or
happen in parallel so that all of this
could happen automatically like across
systems and between vendors and a common
model so that you could just ingest your
CQL and everyone is measuring the same
way and there has been some feasibility
for this like at Mayo they've published
a paper where they were able to do this
they translated cql into sparkle which
is like a graphical query language and
you know they use semantic web
technology and as well as fire data
model to really facilitate this so there
is some promise here however in the
near-term future they're still gonna be
this human intervention this
handcrafting of measure logic and so
what I did for my study is was it
assessed that the benefits and
challenges of interpretability of CTL
there's no current literature that does
an evaluation of cql and so therefore
that's reason I chose to do this my
hypothesis was that CTL would be better
given the fact that it's intended to
solve some of the problems that exist
with HTML QT M so I found a framework
this is from a textbook about algorithms
by a guy named SMED and basically I used
this to sort of frame my my aims but
basically what he says is that for an
algorithm there needs to be explanations
in natural language that define the
different components or the sub
structures and then secondly there needs
to be like a formalism or a structure to
the code to the pseudocode so that
someone can easily decipher it and
convert that into programming code so I
used this framework to sort of ask my
research question which was is cql
better and specifically is it better
than a dressing the curly brace problem
or to you know reduce the burden on the
humans that have to handcraft and
implement electronic clinical quality
measures
so in short I did a qualitative research
design with the propulsive sample of
ecqm developers authors and implementers
I conducted semi-structured interviews
based on the precede procede model so
pre-seed is an precede procede was
developed by a guy named Lawrence Renu
the famous public health practitioner
and so pre-seed is a acronym for
predisposing reinforcing and enabling
constructs in educational diagnosis and
evaluation
so basically pre see it involved
assessing the community factors and
behaviors and social problems the
determinants of a given problem and as
well as the fact that that predisposed
reinforce or enable them and then
proceed is the latter half of academic
stands for policy regulatory of
organizational constructs and
educational environmental development so
this is looking at whether or not
certain programs or resources of
reaching an intended population and
evaluating the behaviors so basically in
plain English what I did was I used this
model to identify each expert
backgrounds their experience with ecqms
and then also thinking more broadly
thinking of ecosystem what they needed
to help improve their ability to
implement author and developing
situation in addition to that I also
chose a measure which had specifications
in CQL and HP m fq d m and i asked the
experts to review those and then for CMS
154 and then let me know what was better
or worse in each representation in their
ability to look at the clinical concepts
and just decipher the logic criteria and
I chose this measure because it was
complex it had a good mix of clinical
concepts that various encounter types
and complex temporal facets between the
clinical concepts which are all sort of
challenges when you try
to decipher logic right area of the 13
participants six were randomized to be
shown the cql version of the measure
first and seven were randomized to be
shown the HK mfq the M version version I
did not just choose CMS 154 at random I
also considered other measures these
were sort of the final floor these were
all official measures included in the
quality payment program I ultimately so
this is how I did my measure comparison
and I pulled out the number of data
elements as a proxy for the complexity I
listed the concepts that are in them
some measures look at medications some
measures look at whether or not
screaming occurred for a certain
condition and then some actually look at
outcome like lab values and then I also
category you know describe the time
issues of time and temporal
relationships and the measures and so I
ultimately decided on CMS 154 because it
was complex it wasn't the most complex
like there was one with 26 QT and 8
elements but also it was a pediatric
measure which I thought that the experts
would have less experience with mostly
people have experience with implementing
in primary care adult populations and so
I thought it'd be good if there is a
measure that they might not have
pre-existing experience with so I
recruited my 13 experts using a proposed
sampling technique I reached out to hl7
clinical quality information working
group there's a cql github repository
with contact information as well as
developers from CMS major authoring tool
I also had contacts that I met working
on evidence now initiative but basically
the profile I was looking for was people
who had experience with developing
authoring or implementing ecqms people
that were experienced in clinical
informatics and familiar with HTML qdm
or c qo i then created an interview
guide based on the precede procede model
as well as my prior work with ecqms and
understanding the challenges so just to
review basically I asked about their
background and their role I asked about
the enabling factors predisposing and
reinforcing factors in the ecqm
environment I asked about the specific
data elements that they thought were
beneficial and challenging with a logic
criteria and then I showed them the cql
and hkm sqdm version and asked them
about the benefits and challenges of
each and then I thought for broadly and
asking luck environments and the policy
and regulatory and materials that would
help facilitate standard implementations
of measures and there was no existing
interview guide to use so I had to
create things based on the lit review in
existing resources and then also the
semi structured interview so I modified
the questions in light of these person's
expertise or what happened during that
conversation and importantly I piloted
the interview up first with - yeah -
interviewees early in the process and my
thoughts I learned how to reorder some
of the questions I got some additional
questions to ask so for the analysis I
use the basic emergent crystallization
approach first I developed a code book
using the lit review and previous work
based on pseudo code conventions and our
understanding of some of the complex
issues with delineating
logic expression precede drugs then the
interviews were conducted and recorded
and transcribed
I coded the transcriptions independently
we reviewed them as a group and then the
themes were pulled out from there using
the emergent crystallization approach
I used Atlas Ti for the management and
analysis of the transcripts and the
coding
so I talked to these 13 experts most of
them worked at academic medical centers
a few were at software vendors a
contractor than one was on a local
health plan all 13 of the people I
talked to you had experience with
implementing ecqms ranging from 2 to 11
years and HTML qdm is about 11 years old
so and then and their me an experience
is six and a half years so pretty
experienced with implementation three of
them had experience with writing and
developing and authoring ecqm
specifications and then about half of
the group had experience working with
CQL and half and briefly reviewed it and
then the one person who had no
experience with CTL had heard of it and
sort of knew what it was and so then
thinking of the enabling factors and
challenges sort of the precede part of
my interview guide so despite the fact
that those 13 people had a wide range of
experiences they all agreed on the
enabling factors and challenges globally
that impact ecqm so for enabling factors
some of the resources that were really
helpful or CMS's EC Qi Resource Center
which is a website which has all the
measures specifications and logic the
National Library of medicines value set
Authority Center has a list of all the
codes in terms that define clinical
concepts the Bonny testing tool is
specifically helpful for validation it's
a tool that can interpret h PM fq d mm
and show complex representations of
logic and again enabling factors in this
context of those programs and services
or resources that are that facilitate
action or behavior and then the global
challenges that came up were really
around the fact that these eCPM
implementations require human
intervention to be able to decipher the
HTML logic and then implement those
against clinical data and so therefore
they're these decisions that have to be
made and then the hardest things to make
decisions around are temporal
relationships navigating encounters
transforming units accurately discuss
retrieving the initial patient
population and then issues are
unregulated of the clinical concepts and
so this is a particularly good quote
that reflects some of the global
challenges that came up it consistently
across my interview
so one thing we really struggled with is
trying to understand what the baseline
population is actually supposed to be or
how you define the denominator because a
lot of these measures they'll just say
within your population people who have
had at least one visit and are over 18
but they don't say what kind of visit
that's women that's limited to and they
don't say exactly how you're defining
our population so within this quote we
see that there people tend to struggle
with for this particular person
struggled with temporal relationships
and identification of the initial
patient population and one thing I mean
sort of obvious but that came up was
that hg m fq d m and c q all they're
very different they look very different
at first glance so again this is HT m fq
d m so it starts with the initial
patient population tells you it should
be these kids three months to 18 years
old during the measurement period and
then it breaks down the encounters and
then the dumped denominator exclusions
which are people that are already taking
antibiotics or that have a competing
diagnosis and then your numerator is
people not taking the antibiotic and
then cql past sort of some of these same
elements but it's um in a different
order but it starts with the same stuff
the kids between 18 three months 18 the
encounters is a little cleaner it's
shorter and then they actually have
encounters and diagnoses separate as
separate things while HPV on once those
together and your denominators written a
bit different the syntax is a little
different but it's the same thing thing
people not on an antibiotic so here's
the side-by-side comparison and i'm
going to zoom in on
to these the different colored boxes are
supposed to represent the same date
elements so for the next few slides of
hqm fqdn is on the top and secure is on
the bottom so this is supposed to be
looking at the initial patient
population so again here you can see the
one of the big differences here is in HK
MF q DM they say the birth date is
greater than equal to three months start
before start of measurement period or
less than equal to 18 years in cql they
actually have a function that's age in
months and they have a function that's
age in years and so they're able to just
say greater than equal to 3 and less
than equal to 18 so there's like less
redundancy with that start before start
of measurement for years but you know
people did not universally think that
this was better there was a lot of
disagreement so some of the 13 people
thought that hpf GBM was better they
liked that redundancy actually and some
people liked this simpler with
representation in CQ all with temporal
relationships it's also sort of the same
thing so here they say that the diagnose
in HTML qdm the diagnosis is less than
or equal to 3 days start after start of
the diagnosis whereas in cql at the
bottom here it says occurs three days or
less so in this case they're actually
trying to use more natural language it's
less a program scripting language here
and so that is supposed to be so some
people thought this was better to
interpret it was like clear what three
days the last minute and some people
actually just preferred it to say less
than or equal to three and then also in
h PM fqdn is not included in this
snippet but they referred to this the
measurement period over and over again
without ever defining it
whereas in cql right this is at the top
of CQ l they tell you the measurement
period in this case
is January 2013 to January 2014 so some
people like that aspect in terms of how
they represented logic in HK MF q DM it
was just this list of boolean operators
like a bunch of ands and ORS and so the
order of things really matters
whereas in cql I sort of mentioned this
they have more things you might see in
SQL unions where clauses they also have
these like identifiers that are defined
and can be reused across things for the
encounter type so in HQ HTM fqdn one
thing that came up consistently is they
talk about so at the top here it's a
diagnosis that happens during a set of
encounter or there or a set of
encounters that have been doing a
diagnosis and people have trouble with
this and so in cql what they did is they
separated this so they just tell you the
valid encounters and then after this
they'll tell you what the valid
diagnosis is and so cql is intended to
be cleaner and so just to recap some
other things there are a few main
categories where cql might be beneficial
so one was around the temporal relations
and encounters which I just showed you
so in CTL right they would say starts
three months before X whereas in the qdm
h came up q DM they say greater than 3
months starts before start up and the
start before start up is something
that's not very clear so here's a good
quote if the encounter diagnosis was
present for more than two years I
couldn't do that in qdm logic I would
have to say the diagnosis was present
for at least two years before the
measurement period and there's an
encounter diagnosis that's the same
thing now in cql I can just say the
encounter diagnosis started more than
two years ago so it's a lot cleaner from
the authoring side changes the qdm
helped the CTO or helped and the CTO
helped tremendously to be able to create
those expressions and make it clearer
another potentially beneficial aspect of
CTL is around readability
so more subjects tended to note that CTL
was simplified and easier to read with
clear in naming expressions like the age
of months and agent years for example an
improved visual aesthetic so here's
another quote so this person initially
is talking about HTML qdm says so
looking at the indentation
I forgot that one of the things I
disliked and personally found confusing
was the way that they put ends together
and or indent to me it's kind of sort of
kind of hard to unwind and reapply that
at first glance and the fact that it
starts with and you know the initial
population equals and and that and that
and that and I think if it started with
initial population equals patient
characteristics etc it would just make
it a little bit more natural language as
you're reading through it and so then he
he actually harkening back to the way
that they did aid in months I think it's
a lot cleaner than the way they
represented as part of the demographics
within cql however again there is
disagreement so this is a quote that
directly contradicts the quote I just
read so you know that the point I just
read the guy did not like the fact that
you had it started with an and and you
had an that and or over and over again
however in this quote this participant
said there I guess it's clearer so you
kind of flip it upside down the
numerator and denominator towards the
top of the screen at the bottom of the
screen you've defined all the data
elements they had and at the top that's
really clear the initial patient
population equals the criteria although
the logic still not super clear
denominator emission population
exclusions you know a bunch of or
statements I mean the two main
differences that I see is that the
elements of the thing are more spelled
out they're more water D so they're more
descriptive so I don't have to reference
their definitions to know what they are
so this person likes that HTM fpdm is
wordy whereas the other person like that
cql was cleaner
another so cql has all these functions
and identifiers that are intended to be
reusable components across measures so
you can define something like children
age three months eighteen years once and
you can just use that across ten
different measures for example so people
like this this purpose quote the person
says that not that pediatric age takes a
lot of time to rewrite or you can set it
up once and reuse it so I know that if
we have to write this every time for a
different measure it might be redundant
however people don't understand all the
different components within CTL
so the takeaway is that you know people
might need more explicit documentation
to understand some of these things like
the reusable components so here this
person is making the assumption that
there are complex data types how it does
typing how it how cql understands the
concepts of time and dates and
interviewers explore the point values
and so here what they want is they want
to know how these things specifically
tie into clinical quality measures and
this relates to some of the results when
I asked people about the policy and
regulatory environmental issues that
they needed or not issues the resources
that they needed to help move cql
forward so this person says I mean to be
fair you're coming from an existing
understanding of things so it's a matter
of explaining your knowledge of HTML and
here's how we're different and better
what the goals are and how it meets
those goals and not to dis HTM F because
it works great but this is this
different way of looking at it and how I
think differently about this then
separately honestly examples examples
examples and Stephanie three examples so
I can understand that because that's how
I learned things and so there are some
existing resources that CMS and the cql
community has put out to try to address
these sorts of things
there's the measured authors guide from
on the e C Qi website that talks lexical
formatting and how to use it and what
some of the
functions and statements means under the
usage wiki and then they have monthly
webinars or cooking with CQL and then
there's also a developers and operas
guide within the cql specification
however people are asking for more
that's been more explicit of
documentation so some of the
implications of these results are that
they're what we learned is that there's
this paradigm shift people have up to 11
years almost a bug you know a decade
experience with HTML qdm and so
therefore even though there are things I
might not be perfect they know what the
components mean and how to decipher them
there are also a variety of tools like
the measuring authoring tool and health
IT vendors themselves are able to read
hMMF qdm and facilitate their validation
or their implementations and so what the
community needs is they need these tools
to be updated to also be able to work
with cql so I think one of the more
beneficial aspects of CQ Oz that it's
intended to be more general and it has
these reusable abstracted components or
these libraries and functions that can
be shared across the measures however
one challenge at this is that if there
is an error in one of these functions or
libraries then it can propagate so if
you make the error once and you apply it
to 10 measures you know how you
introduce an error 10 in 10 measures at
one another factor that we found is that
you know with hkm F 2 DM you don't
really need to have programming
experience to be able to decipher it um
it's sort of just with boolean logic so
if you have any experience of that you
can sort of figure it out how we would
CQL I think that having a technical
background or experience in programming
can directly help you readily use and
cql so in this study all 13 people sort
of had that experience that even with
that experience there interpretability
married for cql and so there's no
annotation currently in bc2 example so I
think that's going to be really
important especially as you think about
the clinical users are non-technical
people that'll be reviewing CQL and so
that's all sort of technical within
expression logic but then also thinking
back to some of the stuff I showed you
about the patient safety and population
health
if cql is not better at increasing the
portability on the ecqm measure
specifications we might be we're not as
effective at increasing population
health and then also increasing the
comparability of performance across
sites that we can tie to payment so in
conclusion our subjects tended to agree
about the enabling factors and
challenges related to ecqm logic
criteria however they disagreed about
the specific ways that these might be
resolved in logic expression and cql
versus h q MF so while CTL is intended
to be better and it has might have more
of this formal structure and grammar
there are still challenges that
prevailing challenges and delineating
ECG and logic that might still exist in
CTL and so as a result implementers
might continue to have to handcraft and
make these local decisions and
uncertainty based on their clinical
knowledge and they're just very
intuition so moving forward I think we
need further training materials
community forums and these examples to
help with the new paradigm shift and so
specifically thinking about the curly
brace problem is cql a step forward
towards addressing this I think kind of
there are these issues around temporal
relations and readability which I think
are especially promising however at a
basic level if you were to just think
about the issue which is that you have
to take these definitions
and then map them manually turn th our
database table or field but that problem
still exists with cql currently so some
suggestions are one for this problem
around propagating errors is they need
some sort of validation tool or some
type of evaluation for people to be able
to point these out and that's theirs
and then secondly I think you know the
call for examples and annotated files is
particularly useful I think especially
one that's clickable like if there's
dysfunction agent months maybe a
hyperlink you can click on it and it
takes you to the guide that clearly
defines what that actually means so that
there's less ambiguity because that's
the goal is to abstract these things
down so that in CQ also it is very clear
so that then you can take that and
create programming further so for future
work I think more evaluation of ciccio's
needed specifically around interpret
ability and I think more training this
baby and melted in the workforce so that
people know how to decipher these things
and then more efforts to standardize the
structure and eliminate there is and
then importantly you know the goal is
that in the future this expression logic
model can have a machine that interprets
cql and CL can be machine readable so
while there have been some models of
this at Mayo that I describe fire and
cemented web technology I think there is
me more effort than that so that we can
get to this standard portable
interoperable ECG on system so that I'd
like to thank my committee dr. David Orr
and it's well I saw Aaron Cohen and
Steve Dedrick dr. Frank banging me read
and treat such epic provided me with
funding to a scholarship to support some
of this work I'd like to think I am
bringing all my husband
[Applause]
so this was super interesting I should
disclose to the audience members I was a
subject in the study do you how do you
how do you see how does sequel handle
those global variables is it for lack of
a better term for them so those things
that you could potentially recycle
through multiple measures right it's a
measure author sort of creates one and
then puts that out across measures it's
not you know current in the current
state that's sort of in because you
don't have that everything's defined in
the that specific measure but when you
have things that are now to find it
outside to measure it almost feels like
that stuff needs to get housed somewhere
as as well as that problem didn't worked
on know as far as I know there's just
this guide it's actually very good
documentation but that's part of the
problem is what people are asking for is
something like that was essential more
than the document something like for all
those functions are clearly explicitly
defined
yeah and then my second question is do
you have in in talking with all these
folks and doing the research that you
did did you get a sense of why CMS sort
of moved so quickly to make this third
standard right because in 2019 this is
how they're gonna publish all their ecq
ends and it feels like it happened
fairly quickly
CMS isn't often known for doing that
that's the variation that I talked about
and the papers I've written that's
actually pretty well understood or at
least acknowledged Dave also wrote a
paper a number of years ago talking
about the inaccuracy and and complexity
of different measures as they moved
right when they moved taste for sqdm
so even ten years ago they rapidly
implemented HTML CDM there was that
variation and uptake basically and so
they're hoping CPI will help but there
might be also
in the rapid uptake of CQL
so it just occurred to me that there's
going to be some opportunities for doing
kind of a natural experiment as people
switch over and I mean I guess you're
kind of wrapping up but I was wondering
if that's something that you've given
any thought to whether there is actually
an opportunity to see what impact that
switch has over towards the cql and how
you would do that yeah I have thought
about it's it's sort of tough there's so
many confounders right because I guess
for a measure where the logic like
really changes or they make like a big
change to the definition I think that
would be a more interesting but if it's
a measure that stayed sort of consistent
for five years
someone who's implemented that measure
doesn't really need to study the seat
pseudo-code anymore right like if you so
you've implemented it once you might
know the relationship between the
denominator and numerator and exclusions
and if there's just minor tweaks over
time you can you've already sort of
mastered that so I don't know if this
switch from HQ map to CQ all we really
matter all that much but if there's
something big like they add a whole new
some some of these measures sometimes
we'll split into having from one
denominator to two or three or something
but I think for those yeah you could do
something like that
but again it's hard to control
especially because what we're talking
about right is this human craft
intervention and handcrafting so I think
you would have to do like a qualitative
aspect every to and ask them did you use
the pseudo code or you know how they
went about
so the natural sort of assumes that
there's some automation you know so the
cql then this is a southern measure and
we compare the CQ of generative mattress
with the old measures and that would be
really interesting to see what kind of
changes there are what not but you know
I think corporately the answer Dave is
that is that this right at this level of
technology this is all just
documentation for how to implement the
measures and if they've already
implemented the measures so you know I
guess I'll turn the question back is
there four measures that are new or
highly revised like you're saying maybe
with the phasing in of cql there could
be a natural experiment cuz there would
be some people who would be implementing
the measures based on the old standard
because they haven't gotten they're not
they haven't taken the courses or
studied online and then other people
maybe are you know farther along and you
know the early adopters versus the late
adopter kind of thing yeah
or you can do it with like you know
people like me I guess a couple of years
ago before I ever implemented a measure
of brand new to HQ map did sort of
randomize so some people that really
don't know what they're doing and you
know you assume that they have equal
experience or something so one group
HTML under CQ on see who gets it right
just along those lines and the
demographics of the 13 people that was
was there six that word authors know
only three it was six had experience
with CQ Island six had like brief
understanding of but three of the
thirteen had authored many so I guess my
question is around if they've had
experience authoring I'm just curious in
the end of responses to which was easier
ocq all over the forum yeah which the
people who've had experience authoring
which one they like better which was
easier for them but that's kind of the
same testing of people who have
experience with perform yeah so yeah I
think your question is like that
there's authors who've used cql so what
was their feedback on the interpret
ability because they so I actually
thought that before talking to those
people like sort of went in thinking
like oh okay
these are the people that have more
experience like you say was he doing
there was actually one of the subjects
broke it down kind of broke down to me
the difference between writing versus
reading like he was kind of better about
it but so he he it was really helpful
and he was talking to me about the
differences like when you write
something you just assume that it makes
sense right as opposed to reading it and
so that interestingly though even those
people who had experience authoring did
not think that cqr was better than all
the time
especially when I showed them CMS 154 a
couple of people actually worked on
authoring that
and they still were confused and they
made it so yeah it's various even for
that group that carries
[Applause]